when my 91 year old mother elia moved in
with me
i thought i was doing her a service
in fact it was the other way around
you see mom was having issues with
memory loss and accepting her age
she looked defeated
i tried to make her as comfortable as
possible
but when i was at my easel painting
i would peek over and see her just there
she'd be staring at nothing in
particular
i'd watch her slowly climb the stairs
and she wasn't the mom i grew up with
i saw instead
a frail
tiny
old woman
a few weeks went by and i needed a break
from my painting i wanted to play with
the new camera i had just bought i was
excited it had all sorts of
dials buttons and settings i wanted to
learn
so i set up my tripod
facing this large mirror
blocking the doorway to the only
bathroom in the house
after a while
i hear
i need to do use of the washroom
five minutes mom i need to do this
15 minutes
later and
i hear again
i needed to use the washroom
five more minutes
then this happened
and this
[Applause]
and then
this
[Applause]
i had
my aha moment
we connected we had something tangible
we could do together
my mom was born in a small mountain
village in central italy where her
parents had land and sheep
at a young age her father died of
pneumonia leaving his wife and two
daughters alone with all the heavy
chores
they found that they couldn't cope
so a very hard decision was made
mom the oldest at 13
was married off
to a complete stranger
twice her age
she went from being just a kid and was
pushed into adulthood
mom had her first child when she was
only 16.
years later and now living in toronto
mom got work in a clothing factory and
still became manager of the very large
sewing department
and because it was full of immigrant
workers
mom taught herself words from
translation books
she then practiced them in french greek
spanish portuguese danish polish russian
romanian hungarian all around the house
i was in awe
of her focus
and determination to succeed at whatever
she loved to do
after that bathroom aha moment
i practiced my newfound camera skills
with mom as portrait model
through all of this she talked
and i listened
she tell me about her early childhood
and how she was feeling
now we had each other's attention
mom was losing her short-term memory but
was better recalling her younger years
i'd ask and she would tell me stories
i listened and i was her audience
i got ideas
i wrote them down and i sketched them
out
i showed her what to do by acting out
the scenarios myself
we would then stage them
so
she posed
and i learned more about photography
mom
loved the process
the acting
she felt worthy again she felt wanted
and needed
and she certainly wasn't camera shy
[Applause]
mom laughed hysterically at this one
the idea for this image came from
an old german film i had seen about a
submarine called da's boat
as you can see what i got instead looked
more like e.t
so i put this image aside i think it was
a total failure because it didn't reach
my particular vision
but mom laughed so hard i eventually for
fun decided to post it online anyway
it got an incredible amount of attention
now
with any alzheimer's dementia there's
a certain amount of frustration and
sadness for everyone involved
this is mom's silent
scream
her words to me one day were
why isn't my head so full of things that
do say
but before they reach in my mouth i
forget
what they are
why
is my head
so full of things to say
but before they reach my mouth
i forget what they are
[Applause]
now
as full-time care partner and full-time
painter
i had my frustrations too
but to balance off all the difficulties
we played
that was mom's happy place
and i needed her to be there too
[Applause]
now mom was also preoccupied with aging
she would say
how did i get so old so fast
so old
so fast
i also got mom to model for my oil
paintings this painting is called the
dressmaker
i remember as a kid
mom sewing clothes for the whole family
on this massive
heavy
sewing machine that was bolted to the
floor in the basement
many nights i would go downstairs
and bring my schoolwork with me
i would sit behind her in this
overstuffed chair
low hum
of the huge motor
and the repetitive stitching sounds were
comforting to me
when mom moved into my house i saved
this machine and stored it in my studio
for safekeeping
this painting brought me back to my
childhood
the interesting part
was that it was now mom
sitting behind me
watching me paint her
working on that very same machine she
sewed at
when i sat behind her
watching her so
50 years earlier
i also gave mom a project to do to keep
her busy and thinking i provided her
with a small camera and asked her to
take at least 10 pictures a day of
anything she wanted
these are mom's photographs
she's never held a camera in her life
before this
she was 93.
we would sit down together and talk
about our work
i would try to explain
how
and why i did them
the meaning the feeling why they were
relevant
mom on the other hand would just bluntly
say
si
no
bella or bruta
i watched her facial expressions
she always had the last say with words
or without
this voyage of discovery
hasn't ended with mom
she is now in assisted living residence
a 10-minute walk away from my home
i visit her every other
her day had gotten to the point where it
was unsafe for her to be in my house
it has a lot of stairs
she doesn't know my name anymore
but you know what that's okay
she's still recognizing my face
and always has a big smile when she sees
me
i don't take pictures of her anymore
that wouldn't be fair or ethical on my
part
and she wouldn't understand the reasons
for doing them
my father
my brother
my nephew
my partner
and my best friend all passed away
suddenly
and i didn't have the chance to tell him
how much i appreciate it
and love them
with mom
i need to be there
and make it a very long goodbye
for me
it's about being present
and really listening
dependents want to feel a part of
something anything it doesn't need to be
something exceptionally profound that's
shared
it could be as simple as walks together
give them a voice
of interaction
participation
and the feeling of belonging
make the time meaningful
life
is about wanting to live
and not
waiting to die
[Applause]
can i get
a wave and a smile for everyone please
this is for you mom
[Applause]